[Music]
International chess professionals
converge in st. Louis for the 2017
spring chess classic Bensimon here for
the 2017 spring chess classic in st.
Louis now today this is day two not
necessarily round two because Group C is
also playing their third round today the
sixth player double round-robin
will see a complete ten rounds while
groups a and B are single round robins
and will only see nine rounds played
through Wednesday May 24 the 2017 spring
chess classic features a combined prize
fund of more than 50 grand win the top
prize in Group A that will get you six
thousand dollars four thousand dollars
is the prize for Group B and the top
prize for Group C is five thousand
dollars that's because Group C is
actually stronger than Group B and after
the second round in Group A here he is
the man now on the board with a full
point grandmaster VAR a Kobe and var
congratulations on your victory against
our own spirits first time you guys had
played and he took you into one big end
game yeah Thank You Ben yeah it was
really interesting I had this position
here
I played 96 and then I had to go back so
obviously here actually play something
like f3 or you know maybe even get a
bishop out I'm not sure this is such a
great idea to take this pawn because of
the route g1 they perhaps even Bishop a6
I think I like this
positional sacrifice if Bishop g2 rook
g1 and all sorts of tactics could happen
on this open G file the strong diagonal
as well here I kind of like this pawn
sacrifice here so I should have played
like this I think I have a you know yeah
pretty nice position here slightly
advantage for sure so I played 96 Queen
e8 I had to go back lost a bunch of
temples and here I think position is
equal I think my opponent maybe Istanbul
this 96 if you just go Knight c3 and
just
you know force me to take and play this
position I don't think it's just equal
here so you played 96 and actually it
became very tricky for him because now I
play this movie five and now I have this
outpost on c6 and there are some small
problems it's still probably equal but
he was getting a long time and I think
he went for this position thinking that
this is just equal but the night is very
poorly placed on a five said okay c1
take take look see it and now important
move rook c3 because it's a fight for a
C file here if he takes I take with the
Queen I'm slightly better and here there
was a nice tactic 96 now he takes Queen
d6 and now the knight cannot move
because c7 work is saying it now I think
white is pressing here some serious
advantage here so I took I did not want
to take back with a pawn even though it
looks natural because of the blockade he
puts on c7 I didn't think I had that
much here you know I can probably press
this position but I like to have this
because the king and queen and game is
just lost so because now the C pawn just
Queens so that was important factor C
played h5 I played h4 and I now if he
just six I just want to move my king
include my king actually because that
was another possibility like in that
famous gamer Nigel short vs. gentiemen
so if he just sits I might be able to
just improve my king you know and maybe
I'm not harm percent sure I was still
going to think but maybe I can even play
like this it's it's not it's a
possibility here
yeah this is very dangerous to play like
this it's just too passive
so dollar plate couldn't be it and now
we get this end game and this is just
you know it basically maybe block
somehow holds but I think be pong gives
me good champions we spend a lot of time
analyzing it seems like block has good
drawing chances but move forty eight he
made a blunder here this f5 and now
allow me to fix this bone structure
therefore this is lost now should have
played a five here with some drawing
chances so this is all normal
I think everything was played correctly
and I obtained the winning position here
actually there are several ways to win
okay seven wins we analyzed rook c7
probably wins original tacos to play
rook c7 but I thought this is also
winning which is I just want so here I
thought if he doesn't do anything my
king simply simply walks to c7 and I
promote my phone so king g6 is met by
king c5 so he's not in time to win the
pawn so if a g5 last try I play king c5
strong move because now I want to go
rook check and put the rook on d6 and
just promote upon so their king b6 rook
c7 and this was a terrible move oxy
seven I thought there is no different
root system but in fact I should just
play doc t7 with the same purpose of D
656 if he captures any of my pawns
it's a typical idea of blockading the
look and the Pontius Queens so the
difference now in the game he had a
check now if he gives me a check this is
completely losing because I go here now
if he goes check I just go here check go
here goes here actually I can give a
check push the King back and King come
see you tonight
Queen upon I get the same position in a
game but like a few temples ahead
so this 97 was a real mistake I could
have Luke c7 was a mistake I could have
cost me the game because now I'm
probably still winning but I had to play
very precisely check push the King to
the background looks like this is still
winning after
all but I definitely give chances you
know but luckily I'm still in time to
Windows this is a nice moment here King
edge hold is just losing after you
capture but this is interesting if it
goes here I go look f3 Queen take take
take I take and now this is very
important that I'm winning this position
by a Tempe here so he's just not at I'm
clipping at 5 and this wins
so yeah this is the game well daro
actually played in the winter classic a
couple of months ago and he did pretty
well for himself and I saw when he came
downstairs with you before you started
analyzing he he seemed a little confused
about something what was he asking you
um he we were thinking whether or not he
had a chance here there was a line here
in this endgame because this is the only
moment where he had some chances because
of my blunder in the endgame so he was
thinking maybe King g5 here but it looks
like it's still losing after all so King
g5 Oh got one at for texting me too
and and I just I just win here because
of the same idea actually yeah this is
yes awesome by Nexus oh yeah I think
overall it was I'm lucky that after that
blunder rook c7 yeah just I had a
similar mistake in a game against Sam
shank on the new year's championship
where I was completely winning and they
made a move that eventually position
became sure I still managed to win
because I'm blonde at the end but I mean
it seems like it's just a little bit of
a trend now you know you know
back-to-back name getting winning
position but not playing that the clean
technique that I'm livid annoyed about
that you know but you know I think I was
still winning at this I think I have to
go home and check but right yes and
speaking of home now making a home in
st. Louis yes yeah warrant Lewis Chris
Corey about 15 minutes away from the
Chess Club and happy to be here you know
I want to play chess so
the place to be for the chess place he
really is happy to be here actually Bart
you were I remember telling you this
this was you told me about the series
the the classic series yeah I even knew
about it yeah I actually discovered it
on the website I saw you know I didn't
know what it was
yes I discovered this and then I think
the first one was already full I
couldn't play but then I asked when a
Tony reach to playing this one and he
invited me to play here
yeah well it's quite the series now
let's take a look after two full rounds
have been played the standings for group
a after today Group A is led by
Alexander II pataw and Georgian player
Georgia Cassius Velia one and a half
each tomorrow in round three Cassius
really takes the black pieces against
world junior champion Geoffrey Jean in
Group E action from Brazil grandmaster
alexander spear joins me right now he
was victorious today against the former
US Junior clothes Chess Champion Oxshott
Chandra congratulations on your victory
Alexander welcome to st. Louis by the
way is this your first tournament you
played here
yeah the first tournament I played here
and it's the first time United States
also very cool I hope your experience so
far has been good yeah yeah I had some
days to take a look around and then
everything was great so far yeah nothing
to complain that's that's a good thing
actually because so many times the
players come here and all they're doing
is playing chess they don't get time to
really go to the zoo or go around so
that is really cool take us through this
game you had with AK shot today well he
decided stick enough to that should be
also okay but at least now I have some I
have some play now this is Kings a bit
exposed he doesn't have the bishop pair
anymore and I decided that I have a good
setup which c4 Knight c3 which was
better than to try 92-93 to go to c4
because it he can defend easily with
Bishop e6 or visual basic
so before I think it's good and I hear I
think he needs to do something fast
before I finish to to develop my paces
now so I thought you to go Queen b6 here
and I think it's good for blacks too
because okay we're going to defend upon
on b2 and here at 5m6 f5 and well if I
take on a5 just look at five and he's
going to change nf2 and take on beat you
so I thought something like Knight c3
but anyway he can take and take on f2
and he's going to win a pound I think so
still I think it should be better for
black anyway but after Bishop e6 dinner
I was happy because position kind of
consolidated and if you go something
like Wendy for here I can go Knight e3
and later the knight can go to situate
e3 so the position I was really happy
here that I thought I was not worth any
more so he went to rook to e8 and
metaphor looks natural and I go over
this 55 square that is quite important
for me so since he was going to tank
trouble and I was not sure what the
player decides to go Quinn c5 because he
needs to make a big decision here it's
going to change and enter in a war send
game or if he's going for 25 and trying
to mate but sacrificing the palm on a7
and I thought he would go Queen g5 and
h4 something like that and I was not
sure about the position but it looks
like white white can hold here because
the Queen is defending well the dark
squares and but I think black still has
counter play here something with
ricochet I don't know or maybe some left
5 its it to unclear but the endgame is
pleasing from it because okay I have a
simple plan that is just push this Queen
side pounds and it's hard for blacks to
do something against it no I would like
to bring my king to e3 first but if if
he brings his king to the Queen side I
think there are more chances default so
I just went before and Anna Coren b5 it
it's quite straightforward plan so he
was let down time trouble right I
thought maybe he would try something
with rook before here
but anyway I have I can take and rook t1
and after what the H might be three I
think it's good
Bishop e6 I can probably take on d4 and
the endgame it should be good for me
because he has no good way to defend
this six power and if d3 I can just
bring the king and the probably this
pawn is going to to fall at some point
so but I thought to do something like
this because the way it went I just
promoted the poundage they're not his
you have some chances to take here and
to thread Bishop e6 and I think he can
have some chances to hold but maybe I
can change probably and to play
something like b6 it's still quite
tricky for him and now I have a plan to
play the seven would be 186 something
like that one so he went Bishop e6 and
after b6 which I think it's maybe the
only move but it's a good one it works
and the point is if like if he takes
doesn't change much because as now
always going to get to the position with
the pawn on b7 and I'm going to play
route d1 anyway and they're going to
rock the seven so there is no good plan
for black to do anything against it so
doesn't matter much if you change the
pawn not and I'm not really using the a5
for the moment so he took on c4 and take
stock c1 and I think here is just just
winging because the seven and rook d1 is
coming out next and rook d7 it ready to
create some counter play on the center
but it's not enough I can just take the
pawn come back and I still have my work
so summer rook c8 plans or even I can go
ping g5 work they do and they six
something something like this so he was
a very cool Alexander fear
congratulations man
and hopefully this tournament keeps on
going your way one and a half out of two
so far and as we speak at the top of the
leaderboard of course is still very
early
how did you become involved with this
tournament and what did you this is your
first time here when did you get the
invite how did you get connected with
st. Louis now it says like two months
ago the alejandro talks with music
they're going to make dis tournament and
they were thinking about inviting me and
Talia it's a great day it's never been
to United States and would be a good
experience to being like main city of
chess now so I was quite happy but if
you had to do the visa so it was a lot
of logistics to do it at this event all
right well there you go
Alejandro Ramirez thank you very much so
let's take a look at the standings after
round number 2 in Group B round 2 saw
every single game in Group B be a
decisive one with three players sitting
atop the leaderboard at two each
tomorrow's game of the day looks to be a
wonder Liang with the white pieces
taking on JJ Ali more on D Grand Master
Samuel Semyon stands in clear first in
Group C today he had two big victories
and is the first player in any of the
field to stand alone at the top
tomorrow's game of the day in Group C
let's stay with Sam as he plays black
against Ruth Bingley stay with us
through Wednesday May 24th as every
round begins at 1:00 p.m. with the
exception of the final day see the move
by move live as it happens at chess 24
calm and us chess champs calm